Programmiermodelle sind grundlegende Spezifikationen, die definieren,
wie Software strukturiert
und ausgeführt wird – sie bieten einen Rahmen,
damit Entwickler Algorithmen ausdrücken
und Code organisieren können, wobei oft Low-Level-Details
der darunterliegenden Hardware oder Ausführungsumgebung abstrahiert werden.
Verschiedene Modelle eignen sich für unterschiedliche Problemtypen
und Hardware-Architekturen und bieten
unterschiedliche Abstraktionsniveaus
und Steuerungsmöglichkeiten. In diesem Kapitel
schauen wir uns Quanten- und klassische Programmiermodelle an
und sehen, wie wir sie kombinieren können, um Algorithmen zu betreiben,
die
Wir beginnen mit dem Programmiermodell
für einen Quantencomputer. Ein grundlegendes Programmiermodell,
das nahezu allen Quantenentwicklern bekannt ist,
ist der Quanten-circuit. Wir werden
nicht im Detail auf Quanten-circuits eingehen,
da wir bereits viele hervorragende Ressourcen haben,
darunter eine Vorlesung von Joan Waters.
Wir erwähnen nur, dass der circuit aufgebaut ist aus
einer Reihe von Leitungen, sogenannten Wires, die qubits darstellen,
sowie gates, die Operationen auf Quantenzuständen repräsentieren,
und einer Reihe von Messungen.
Ein weiteres wichtiges Konzept des Programmiermodells
für
Diese Primitives repräsentieren die häufigsten Aufgaben,
die Nutzer mit einem Quantencomputer erledigen möchten.
Derzeit sind zwei Primitives verfügbar:
Sampler und Estimator. Der Sampler gibt dir die Möglichkeit,
einen Zustand abzutasten, der durch einen Quanten-circuit vorbereitet wurde,
und der Estimator ermöglicht es dir, den Erwartungswert
einer Observablen für ein System im Zustand zu schätzen, der durch deinen Quanten-
circuit vorbereitet wurde. Das letzte Konzept,
über das wir in diesem Abschnitt sprechen werden,
ist die Transpilation. Die Transpilation
ist der Prozess, einen gegebenen Eingabe-circuit so umzuschreiben,
dass er der Topologie eines bestimmten Quanten-
geräts entspricht
und auf verrauschten Quantencomputern ausgeführt werden kann.
Ähnlich wie klassische Compiler
verändert eine Transpilations-Routine die
Struktur des circuits schrittweise durch eine Reihe von Durchläufen (Passes).
Jetzt sprechen wir über klassische Programmiermodelle.
Es gibt viele Programmiermodelle
für klassische Computer,
aber in diesem Kapitel konzentrieren wir uns auf zwei:
das parallele Programmiermodell
und Task-Workflows. Durch die Kombination dieser beiden Modelle
mit Quanten-Programmiermodellen
lassen sich nahezu beliebige hybride
Quanten-klassische Workflows jeder Komplexität ausdrücken.
Das parallele Programmiermodell
teilt ein Programm in Teilprobleme auf, die gleichzeitig ausgeführt werden können.
Es gibt zwei Hauptparadigmen des parallelen Programmierens:
Shared-Memory-Parallelismus und Distributed-Memory-Parallelismus.
Für unsere Zwecke konzentrieren wir uns hier auf das Distributed-Memory-Modell.
Ein Distributed-Memory-Modell
verwendet unabhängige Prozesse auf separaten Kernen
oder Knoten, wobei jeder Prozess seinen eigenen Speicher hat
und die Kommunikation über Message Passing erfolgt. Es gibt
einige Konzepte, die nützlich zu kennen sind.
Das erste ist der Prozess,
eine unabhängige Instanz des Programms,
die auf einem separaten Kern läuft.
Dann gibt es den Rank, einen eindeutigen Bezeichner des Prozesses,
und schließlich das Single Program,
Multiple Data (SPMD) Abstraktionsmodell,
ein Abstraktionsmodell
für Berechnungen, bei dem eine einzige Instanz des Programms
auf mehrere Knoten verteilt wird.
Der Quellcode ist also gleich,
aber die Daten auf den Knoten sind unterschiedlich.
Das parallele Programmiermodell wird ausgeführt,
auf folgende Weise:
Ein einzelnes Programm wird auf mehrere Knoten verteilt
und startet mehrere parallele Prozesse.
Der Kontrollfluss des Programms wird durch den Rank bestimmt,
also den Bezeichner des Prozesses,
und die Kommunikation erfolgt
über Message Passing.
Ein Task-Workflow-Programmiermodell
abstrahiert Berechnungen als Graph oder DAG (Directed Acyclic Graph),
wobei jeder Knoten des Graphs eine bestimmte Aufgabe
oder einen Job darstellt und Kanten Abhängigkeiten und Daten
sowie Reihenfolgen repräsentieren. Beispiele findest du in unserer Dokumentation.
Die Sequenz, über die wir im Quanten-
computing immer sprechen – Mapping, Optimierung,
Ausführung und Nachbearbeitung –
ist ein Task-Workflow-Programmiermodell,
bei dem alle Aufgaben nacheinander
in der Pipeline ausgeführt werden.
Aber mit Task-Workflows
sind wir nicht an eine sequenzielle Ausführungsreihenfolge gebunden
und können Aufgaben parallel ausführen.
Jede Aufgabe oder jeder Workflow kann ein eigenständiger paralleler Job sein,
sodass du diese Modelle frei kombinieren kannst,
um Algorithmen zu beschreiben,
die beliebig komplex sind.
Lass uns einige der erlernten Konzepte auf Code anwenden.
Zuerst versuchen wir, ein einfaches Hello World
mit dem parallelen Programmierparadigma auszuführen.
Wir verwenden OpenMPI,
eine Implementierung des MPI-Protokolls,
dem Standard für Message Passing
beim parallelen Programmieren.
Zunächst müssen wir unser Programm bereitstellen.
Hier verwenden wir mpi4py,
das Python-Binding
für MPI, und wie du siehst, nutzen wir den Rank, um den
Kontrollfluss des Programms zu steuern.
Schauen wir uns nun unser Submission-Skript an.
Wie du siehst, verwenden wir zwei Knoten,
eine Aufgabe pro Knoten in der normalen Partition.
Jetzt starten wir unser Programm – wir warten kurz
und können dann die Ergebnisse unseres Jobs überprüfen.
Wie du siehst, haben wir die Log-Ausgaben unseres Programms.
Hier verwenden wir zwei Knoten und zwei Prozesse,
die jeweils durch einen Rank identifiziert werden,
wie du hier in der Ausgabe siehst:
Rank Null und Rank Eins, die den Kontrollfluss
unseres Programms steuern.
Wie du siehst, hat der Prozess mit Rank Null
eine Nutzlast an den Prozess mit Rank Eins gesendet,
und der Prozess mit Rank Eins hat sie empfangen.
Jetzt sprechen wir auch über Task-Workflows.
Es gibt Tools, sogenannte Workflow-
Management-Systeme, die speziell dafür entwickelt wurden,
komplexe Workflows auszuführen.
Aber um dich nicht zu überfordern, verwenden wir das eingebaute
Dependency-Feature in Slurm,
um diese Berechnungsgruppen zu erstellen.
Zunächst müssen wir die Aufgaben unseres Workflows
bereitstellen. Das ist der gleiche Code.
Der Vorteil, jede dieser Aufgaben –
Mapping, Optimierung, Ausführung,
Nachbearbeitung – als separaten Schritt zu haben,
ist, dass wir für jede Aufgabe eindeutige Ressourcenanforderungen
festlegen können. Zum Beispiel benötigen Mapping, Optimierung und
Nachbearbeitung keinen
Zugriff auf Quantenressourcen,
daher können wir sie auf einer klassischen Partition ausführen.
Die Ausführungsaufgabe hingegen benötigt
Quantenressourcen, daher führen wir sie auf der Quanten-
Partition aus.
Jetzt nutzen wir das Dependency-Feature, um Aufgaben
zu einem Workflow zu verketten.
Wie du siehst, läuft gerade noch
unser Sbatch-Befehl mit dem Flag --parsable,
der die Job-ID zurückgibt.
Dann können wir diese Job-ID
als Abhängigkeit an andere Aufgaben
oder Jobs übergeben. Wie du siehst, starten wir
Jobs im Workflow mit der Abhängigkeit.
Sobald der gesamte Workflow abgeschlossen ist, können wir die Ergebnisse prüfen.
Und wie du siehst, erhalten wir unseren Erwartungswert zurück.
Außerdem können wir alle
Ergebnisse aus jedem der Schritte einsehen.
Die sind ebenfalls hier zu finden.
Das war es zum Abschnitt über Programmiermodelle.
Im nächsten Kapitel sprechen wir über fortgeschrittene
Algorithmen.